[Music]
I'm not ashamed to say it you look
incredible you're very fit this makes
thank you thank you very
what do you are you a guy that works out
a lot what's it about I'm sick you're
sick I'd like to and no I I will I don't
look that great I I just I don't eat
like a pig
I don't you know sleep 15 hours a day I
guess I you know when I was when I was
younger I enjoyed a drink now and again
and I did not look as as as good then
you know my face tends to gather water
yeah
quite quite efficiently I tend to
Shatner or as well our net likes to say
I look like I just ate a Chinese baby so
you get what's called you get the round
I have this too being Irish if I have
too much potato in a little too much ham
I guess around Ted Kennedy balloon head
you know and it happens it's in the
genes
so you got it so it's with you it's
about just that what you're eating
you're not drinking right now are you
because you look beautiful Conan does he
not look great
this this is because I'm drinking a lot
yes that's are you doing something what
are you doing what are you up to what am
i up to you know actually I changed my
diet a little bit I didn't work out I
did I took I did I I tried to you know
do the non-dairy gluten-free just to try
it see what it's all about and he do
actually feel better yeah it's working
for you well thank you so much I'm
coming over there yeah no no no you stay
where you are you stay right where you
are
I put on a lot of moisturizers I don't
do that all I do the moisturizer you
don't do that no who does is Rob Lowe
was well a couple of weeks ago the guy
walks around he has moisturizer in his
pocket so he yes he does not even in a
jar he just reaches his hands in and
there's he takes it out that is the
secret is that he's moisturizing 24/7
but my my my wife makes me hydrate
religiously she's she's she's telling me
to use the toners and and and those the
the facial creams and hand creams and
all stuff yeah I mean does Liza make you
do a bunch of stuff you don't want to do
no she the only thing my wife did was I
my hard core as I said I grew up in an
Irish Catholic family and all I did was
eat giant ham sandwiches so you can't do
it all I ate and then I met my wife and
I went into the open the refrigerator
and there was like kale and pasta that's
made of like a sunflower and Senna and I
became enraged I was like where's my
giant ham and she was like we're not
doing that anymore and I'd helped me it
helped me a lot it didn't rages other
parts of your body too it really bangs
you up right it's tough on the valve
when you start eating all that all that
kind of stuff what are you talking about
well you know what you speak for
yourself it's
it's all got to get out you know my you
put you put that stuff in its got to
find a way out
oh it knows exactly how to get out but
there's no finding a way out but B the
whole system set up
no but kale and kale kale kale is a
grumpy traveler through the body ok
kales not happy as it goes through your
body my wife want to think she maybe she
made me go do a colonic the other day
you had a colonic had a colonic I've
never had a colonic in my life well
listen you're gonna be surprised what
comes out of your body but so so I'm
there I'm on my side you know I'm at the
colonic place I'm following directions
we this is not gonna get terrible but by
the way rest relax
none of this will air good but I I'm I'm
on my side behaving myself and I'm
breathing and I'm I'm allowing things to
happen and I'm just staring at the wall
and I'm thinking this is marriage this
is this is what it is this is this is
behaving and doing as you're told and
eating your kale and your pasta made up
yours for hours yeah and we look
incredible
well you look you know boy I know you I
look like an actress in a Lifetime movie
but but what I'm saying is you say all
kinds of like when you talk about I
don't want to get too graphic but you
say like oh stuff comes out of you it's
like know what's coming out of you
besides the obvious down there you act
like license plates are coming out
during the colonic yeah there was a
license plate it was a bike license
plate and a small tire but it was off a
tricycle
and I feel great uh-huh all right
you